there's this huge misconception in the  medical community that a diet  high in protein is bad for your kidney  there's no research that shows that a  high protein diet protein from any  source  is bad for the human kidneys and so i've  started using the phrase meat is good  for your kidneys prove me wrong show me  the research i've yet to have a single  controlled research studies thrown in my  face saying you're wrong big guy there  is no research that shows that yet the  average medical doctor dietitian  nutritionist they will scare them to  death oh you need to avoid especially  red meat somehow red meat is magical  it's much much worse for your kidneys  than than you know white meat  but they're okay that's great so where's  the research oh then you hear the  crickets chirping because there is no  research that supports that whatsoever  which makes that  at best a hypothesis at worst a myth or  a big fat lie